so how do we know that the church is a
visible
institution um instead of merely just
being a spiritual body of Believers like
the Protestants uh assert um against the
Catholic because the Bible talks about
they're being Shepherds on Earth to Pro
to protect the flock of God from
ravenous wolves right and FAL false
teachers so is the church something on
Earth established and preserved
I don't know you went silence so I can't
hear you oh yes yes so then if the
church is something on
Earth and it's
something that God uses as the mechanism
to preserve the truth the truth that is
needed for salvation and
sanctification in what way will it be
merely invisible now I'm not saying the
Protestant is merely invisible they
saying there's a visible Church but in
that church it consists of Believers and
unbelievers but the invisible church is
that which consists only of regenerated
Believers so it's a little more
complicated than that so an informed
Protestant does not deny there's a
visible
Church they're saying there's a visible
Church what they're saying is not
everyone in the visible church is truly
a member of the body of Christ so
they're trying to distinguish between
the true members of the body of Christ
and the Wolves right right who are not
of Christ but still are part of our
fellowships you get my point I do so I
in a way I can see the point of the
argument what do I mean in a way I do
agree not everyone who says he's of
Christ is truly of Christ and not anyone
who begins a race will endure and Paul
says there'll be wolves who come in the
midst of us not sparing the flock so I
don't know of any Protestant who denies
the church is visible what the argument
is is that not everyone that's a
Christian who's part of the church on
Earth is truly a Christian now I don't
know if I would really disagree with
that I I mean because if he's saying to
me not everyone on Earth is part of the
body of Christ I agree not everyone who
goes to church who thinks he's a
Christian a True Believer I agree but
does that mean yeah so go ahead oh it's
like right there's plenty of people that
are Christian in name alone and just go
about the rich go about the uh the you
know just go to church on Sunday yes so
if that's what they mean I don't really
have a disagreement but if they're
saying that that somehow implies that
the church on
Earth will somehow and they don't imply
this they won't say this they're not
restorationist but I'm saying if by that
they mean that somehow that means that
the Lord will not be personally involved
and preserving the church by raising up
true men of God true Shepherds to
protect the flock from false Doctrine
and to give the correct interpretation
of scripture and preserve the scriptures
then they're
wrong so unless they restorationists
they will not disagree with this point
that there are true Bishops empowered by
the spirit preserving the true correct
interpretation of scripture and the
correct scriptures and God has placed
them
upon the Earth from the time of the
Apostles Until the End of the Age and
that's where the problem Begins for them
because if I take 1 Timothy 3:15
seriously they'll say well it's not the
Catholic church I go that's not my
argument listen to my argument I tell
the Protestant listen to my argument
that's not my argument let me tell you
what my argument
is the Bible says that the household of
God is the Church of the Living God it's
the pillar and bul workk of the truth
meaning God will preserve the truth
through
this living
institution the church so if I want to
know the truth of God I have to find it
in the
church the church is entrusted with the
preservation of the truth the protection
of the truth and the exposition of the
truth so since God's truth cannot be
corrupted cannot be lost that means the
me mechanism by which God preserves the
truth and allows access to it on Earth
because truth in heaven does nothing
beneficial for us on Earth it does me no
good not to have access to God's truth
if it's in heaven God's truth has to be
accessible to us on Earth if God wants
us to be saved right right okay so the
mechanism that God uses to preserve the
truth and violence meaning it cannot be
corrupted it's the church so then what
was the Church of the second century
what it look like who are the men who
were The Heirs of the Apostles what did
they teach what did they say what was
the church in the thir Century what was
the church in the 4th Century that's
when you slowly start seeing
protestantism is a no no but they want
to then change the argument to well
wasn't the Catholic church I said I
don't care if it's Catholic or Orthodox
I want to know if you believe the
promises of scripture which you claim
you do then you must believe that the
mechanism because how does God preserve
the truth the church how does God
protect the truth truth the church is
right there 1 Timothy 3:15 is not going
anywhere the mechanism that God uses to
preserve protect the truth from being
corrupt or lost is the church so that
means God will work in time in such a
way there always be true Bishops true
leaders preserving the truth and
interpreting correctly so now I what
tradition is correct yes now I look at
the history of the church and I look at
the people in the second century and
they're men like Justin Martyr aronas
now tulan wasn't a church father he fell
away and followed a prophet named
montanis who claimed the spirit was
giving Revelations but he still and they
still were trinitarians but nonetheless
he followed him shamefully then I go to
the third century and I'm looking at
people like hippius and I'm looking at
people like you know novas and I'm
looking at people like siral and so on
and so forth and they are not teaching
Protestant teaching they're teaching
Perpetual virginity of Mary this is a
fact you can't get around it they're
teaching Eucharist as the sacrifice of
our Lord his actual body his flesh and
blood they're teaching water baptism and
regeneration they're teaching prayers
for the dead Eucharist for the dead
they're teaching intercession of saints
they're teaching Mary's Perpetual I
mentioned that her Purity and a host of
things that if they were to come into
your church today and you're Protestant
and you didn't know who they were you'd
condemn them as
Heretics however if you were going to
church in their day and you taught what
you did you'd be condemned as Heretics
and thrown out of the church right so
that either means they were all corrupt
the truth was lost Jesus failed because
man was mighty than Jesus or he lied or
the Bible is a lie it's not God's word
whatever position you opt for you're
going to end up destroying the Christian
faith right the argument that I have
heard uh formulated is that either
Christ or that God let his visible
Church fall into apostasy over the first
1500 years and it wasn't right no
because Jesus is talking about building
his church on earth and the spirit
guiding them into all truth on Earth not
in heaven
that can't be that's a lie from the pit
of Hell here so you're saying then again
Jesus didn't mean what he said of what
use is it for Jesus to preserve the
church in heaven and guide people in
heaven all the truth when that truth is
needed on Earth to save and preserve the
lost right right so then that means
these promises are not on void because
last time I checked it's talking about
on Earth it's not saying in heaven on
Earth so either
Christ is faithful and therefore
protestantism is a cancer or Christ
failed or the Bible's a lie either way
you destroy Christianity here let me
show you does this sound like he's
talking about the invisible Church even
if it's invisible church that invisible
Church must be made manifest on Earth
because it's talking about preserving
the truth on Earth Here Matthew 168 you
go and I tell you you are Peter and on
this rock I will build my church and the
powers of Death Shall Not Prevail
against it but according to them it did
right correct yeah that's exactly what
they're asserting exactly blasphemy why
do you think I couldn't remain because I
knew these passages and these passag
kept hammering at me how about this one
read it from John 161 12-13 and I have
yet many things to say to you but you
cannot bear them now when the spirit of
truth comes he will guide you into all
the truth for he will not speak on this
own author auth but whatever he hears he
will speak and he will declare to you
the things that are to come so he's
talking about guiding them into all
truth in
heaven on Earth on Earth so even if he
preserves invisible church that
invisible church will be preserved
where here on Earth so therefore it will
be visible for us to see and know right
correct yeah yeah that's these
objections are pathetic but here second
through now in case they say well the
Holy Spirit was only promised to them
even though it says forever because
forever means he begins with the
apostles but he remains with their
successors now how do I know Paul
talking to Timothy 2 Timothy 1 13-
14 follow the pattern of the sound Words
which you have heard from me in the
faith and love which are in Christ Jesus
guard the truth that has been entrusted
to you by the Holy Spirit who dwells
within us so the the Holy Spirit abandon
their successors or did he remain with
their successors no th this verse says
otherwise and would the Holy Spirit then
Empower their successors to preserve the
truth yes and would the Holy Spirit
continue to empower the True Believers
and Heirs of the Apostles till Christ
returns
absolutely there you go in fact here
look what then Timothy is supposed to do
second Timothy 2 verses 1- two you then
my son by strong in the grace that is in
Christ Jesus and what you have heard
from me before many witnesses entrust to
Faithful Men Who will be able to teach
others also you see where we got the
doctrine Apostolic
succession it's from here Apostolic
succession the apostles repl appoint
Bishops to succeed them because the
Bishops are there as the apostles then
they appoint successors and they appoint
successors and they appoint successors
so if the Bible teaches this and the
Bible is God's word
God cannot lie so I tell the Protestant
show me who the true Bishops were in the
second century and what they believed
they're not Catholic Orthodox I don't
care what did they believe what did they
teach third this exact this is exactly
what I was looking into because I wanted
to know what is true Christianity
because it definitely wasn't
non-denominational which I fell out of
Faith with because
I shallow theology they taught me that
at school and even even if they say it's
not Orthodox Catholic I say okay now I'm
going to do you one
better I want you to explain to me how
is it Oriental Orthodox Eastern Orthodox
and the Catholics and the Syrian Church
they're all in Schism by the way they're
not in communion
Syrian Church of the East and the
Catholics are imp partial Community but
Oriental Orthodox East no they're not
right now all these churches in here
they're in my comment section so people
when you do the Replay for the chat read
Oriental Orthodox easn or othodox
Assyrian Church Catholic I'm going to
ask them a series of questions look how
much
agreement they have without Sol scripter
to scripter and they've been in Schism
let me just explain the Assyrian Church
Schism broken off from the rest of
Christians in the
400s the what we call the Oriental
Orthodox the
mosites they became in Schism
400s cut off from the
400s Eastern Orthodox Catholics 10 54 in
Schism now how do you account for the
high degree of agreement when they
haven't been in fellowship and in Schism
and in the case of the Assyrians and the
Orthodox from The 400s Case of the
Oriental Orthodox but in case of Eastern
Orthodox Catholics since 1054 now watch
Oriental Orthodox UK Coptic Sak Orthodox
Eastern Orthodox Catholics Assyrian do
you all accept that the Eucharist
becomes the actual body
flesh and blood of Christ watch the
comment section without Sol script to
script watch
here now those of you come later watch
do the chat
replay okay watch here see that No Sol
scripture No to scripture in Schism they
didn't have internet they didn't have
email right second question all of you
do you accept the Perpetual virginity of
Mary yes watch yeah yep I want them to
see so I want to know how is it without
solar scripture total scripture they
have a higher degree of agreement with
you guys who go Sola script to to
scripture and you have a
higher degree of disagreement see
Perpetual Virginia Mary do you all
believe that the Lord kept her pure not
talking about a m conception I'm talking
about do you all agree the Lord kept his
mother pure
watch see they're going to say yes and
as you're answering these questions I'm
going to ask you four more do you all
accept water baptismal regeneration that
in the act of water baptism God sends a
spirit to make you alive regenerate you
unite you to Christ and bring about
forgiveness of
sins I'll ask the same series of
questions to a Lutheran Anglican
Reformed Baptist Independent Baptist
Church of Christ non-denominational and
they're all over the map okay do you all
accept infant B
baptism without Sol scripture or to
scripture see this is what the
Protestants don't emphasize why they
have so much agreement even though
they're in Schism and they don't follow
solar scripture Toto scripture but you
guys with solar scripture and TOA
scripture and in communion can
agree see that all right so you see it
now do you all agree that you can pray
for the dead in Christ those who've died
in Christ pray for them
watch
here CCH it look at it they're going to
say oh yeah yeah do you all accept
intercession of saints that those who in
heaven are alive and they can pray for
you there you go and if I mention
priesthood now I want you Protestants to
explain these churches are in
skism some of them since the
400s Eastern Orthodox Catholics since
1054 no internet no email no facts
without to script solar scriptura why do
they have all of this in common and they
agree on these doctrines no
disagreements on these doctrines you
guys with Sol script to scriptura and in
communion and you can't even agree on
these doctrines you're all over the map
and it didn't just start with you it
started with Martin Luther John Calvin
you they couldn't even agree what does
that tell you you know what that tells
me I'm going to tell you what that tells
me these doctrines must have been in
place already universally accepted
before the
schisms so if the Assyrian Church
believes this and the Oriental Orthodox
believe this but they were in Schism in
the 400s that means these teachings must
go before the 400s and must have been
widespread among these Christians so now
that means universally even before the
400s and we have written documents that
say you can as far as our extent written
sources find them as far as the second
century
right that means the Christians all over
the world no internet no Fox no
Telly they didn't have all the books of
the Bible between two covers some have
more books than others and they're all
teaching water baptismal
regeneration they're all teaching the
Eucharist becomes the flesh and blood of
Christ they're all teaching you can be
caught off and salvation they're all
teaching oh by the way confession of
sins even the Assyrian Church believes
in confession of sins later on they
stopped it but they'll tell you
historically people had to confess to
their priests why did they stop it I
don't know they're all teaching
confession this is universal confessing
your sins to the priest or the bishop
they're all teaching Mary's Perpetual
virginity they're all teaching that she
was kept pure they're all teaching
intercession of saints they're all
teaching praying for the dead and
offering the Eucharist for the dead
they're all teaching teaching this so if
these doctrines are corrupt these
doctrines are false there was no church
in the second century so the Mormons are
right Joe's Witnesses are right the
campbellites are right the Adventists
are right Jesus left the church allowed
it to be corrupt and only thought about
restoring it 1700 years later which
would be
blasphemy that's why cowards like James
White will never tell you that these
Christians were false Christians and
he'll never tell you upright they were
not saved he'll just say we don't judge
people we judge motiv but hold on where
is the
gospel in fact I'm going to ask all
these CH Christians do you Christians
Eastern Orthodox Oriental Orthodox
Syrian Church Catholic Church do you
believe in solid as defined by Martin
Luther that once you believe in Christ
God declares you righteous doesn't make
you righteous but then starts making you
righteous after you make that
confession do any of you believe that
watch NADA zip zero but now we got a
problem I will give a million bucks to
all these Protestants show us in the
early church that any of the early
Christians even Augustine taught now
notice my challenge Sol as you define it
show us where any of them taught that
you're justified by faith alone but by
faith alone they mean what you mean that
once you believe in Christ you're
Justified and that it is a forensic
righteousness where you're declared
righteous but made righteous show me
anyone teaching that in the early church
now I know what they'll do they'll quote
someone saying well just y faith alone
but they don't then quote what that
father meant by faith if you read in
context faith for him meant being
faithful to do the commandments so don't
give me a father saying just what I'm
asking show me where he defined it like
Martin Luther you're not going to find
it so if they didn't Define it that way
then you're basically telling me there
was no gospel then how was any of them
saved right
yep it's sad man but it is what it is so
brother you made a right choice not
going to protestantism but I hope that
answer your question you have another
question